what type of conductivity so take it
away
okay so let's start
with talking about hyperconductivity in
general so
we have a function
the Boolean Cube
the quality test
it's fully expansion
well the character of sky is an
autonomal basis
given as the product
of the elements in s
and
on the Boolean Cube we have a certain
process called the noisy process
okay
what's this the process does we take the
Boolean Cube
foreign
that gives us some a y in a small
neighborhood of x
and what and and the
and then we are going to Define an
operator called The Rose operator that's
defined by averaging a function over
this y that's close to X
so how is it given a formally
so we are going to Define why
according to this
distribution n Epsilon X
and well
each
y i
so there are two possibilities either we
remembered x i so
with some probability Epsilon we
remember the x i and then y i is x i
and with sample ability we forget it and
so
and
so after we forget it we resample it
uniformly out of -1 1.
foreign
so we start with an x
it will start with some X in the Boolean
Cube and then we get somewhere that's
close to X by looking at all the
coordinates of X each coordinate will
remember it and then we let y I be x i
and if we forget it we choose it to be
informed at random out of -1 1 and
eventually we get this y that's close to
X
and then Associated to this random walk
we have a smoothing operator so we can
Define the noise operator
given by taking the expectation
so it's value on X to f of x is the
expectation of a y
chosen in this small neighborhood of
F of Y
and the hyperconductivity theorem that
we're going to talk about we can
um already state it so we have
um the lpnome of the function so if we
have a function on
build value function
so not necessarily Boolean it's been on
is defined as the expectation
of s to the p
and
and in probability spaces we have
so in probability spaces the Pinon
is at most qno
if p is smaller than Q
so why is that let's prove it in the
case for p is equal to 2 and K is equal
to 4 and P
so we want to
and
utter bound the expectation of
F squared
squared by the expectation of f to the
4.
and
foreign
how are we going to do that we can write
this expectation of f squared as an
inner product between F squared
and the constant one function
and then apply a question Schwarz to say
that this is at most
f
because the phone of one
is one so we get the two normies at most
the phono and it's two in general that
uh
when p is smaller than Q
so if we can imagine this picture
that we have the L2 unit ball
F such that the two Norm of f
is that most one
the big L2 unit ball and inside we have
The L4 unit board
and
usually when we have an operator we can
talk about its con contraction
probability that the it sends the unit
ball into itself but the noise operator
has this very strong hyper contraction
properties that it manages to squeeze
the big ball into the small ball so
inside
we have this
T of 1 over 3 of
the LT board
pictures so let's take the theorem
so we have a function
really a values function on the Boolean
Cube
and we have Epsilon
that's smaller than
one over root Q minus one
and then we get the T Epsilon of f
a few Norm of that
is at most
foreign
this is the picture for Q equal to four
so
if we start with the function in the L2
bar this T Epsilon operator it squeezes
it into the unit and forward
are there any questions so far
yeah
okay why so every okay corresponds to
random work is a conduction this follows
from a antonym equality I can prove that
and
okay so we have
um
so let's say you're trying to compute
and yes so let's move it for this
operator
foreign
and then we are trying to take absolute
value and take it to the fifth power
and take expectation over X
I'm using Jensen we can
put the absolute the absolute value
inside and say that this is at most
the expectation over X and Y
of
FY to just put a p
but then we can use the property that
when we choose X randomly and Y
according to the noisy process we get
why this distributed uniformly in the
Boolean Cube so this is the
enormous
okay the only thing that was important
is that this random Works since the
uniform distribution into the uniform
distribution otherwise it works in every
station
with
foreign
with respect to the degree
yeah if we have a function
then the Epsilon of f
is the sum
of Epsilon to the s
times F flat s times
give the proof because
simple enough
so okay so we have this operator OT
Epsilon is a linear operator so it's
efficient to show it for this character
Skys
and this T Epsilon of chi s
is the
expectation
X expectation over
a noisy version of x
of the product of I and S
of y i
which is
Chi s of Y
and now we can use the fact that these y
eyes are independent because we're doing
everything Independence in each
coordinate so this is the product over
ins
over the expect of the expectation
why I
but then y i is
x i with the probability Epsilon and
otherwise it's uniformly distributed so
with probability Epsilon Y is just x i
and otherwise it has expectation zero so
this is equal to the Epsilon to this
okay
I'm sorry
with public Epsilon Epsilon times x i
yeah so we get
[Music]
okay so intuitively what happens here is
that this noise operator of it basically
kills the high degrees we have this
power Epsilon to this which means that
uh
it keeps the low degrees alive the
constant degrees but it
essentially kills the hydrogrades
but and we could have we could we could
have instead of
instead of applying the noise operator
we could have just uh brutally and take
just the sum of all these efforts KS
what is small but then we wanted this uh
nice properties that are preserved like
when we apply this the Epsilon we get a
bounded function and
much more convenient that we have a nice
operator to do the job for us and then
just do things
all right so
let's
um
show the first quality of that
and
the corner is going to be that if we
have a low degree polynomial
then we can have a bound on its qnomes
okay
so let's start with the polynomial
that's homogeneous integrating
and if we take any cue that is list two
you get that and then
we get the qnome of f
is the most Q minus one to the double
two
times the two normal path
the proof here is again very simple so
we take a
and if we let
B one over root Q
and then we get that
the Epsilon of f
the Q no movie
on the one hand is equal to
Epsilon to the D times the Q Norm of f
on the other hand it's at most yeah so
it's one of those called Q minus one and
on the other hand it's most the two
normal f
and that's basically rear engine that's
complexible
and explore in general that if we have
an operator that that is
hypercontractive
we can look at its eigenfunctions and
reduce that they have this property the
qnome is bounded in terms of the two
Norm
okay
what
so how to think about these moment
bounds
and
so one example to keep in mind
if the function
which is the sum of the x i
divided by 10
this function
and its distribution
it converges to the
normal distribution
and
if we put the infinity Norm this means
that f is always bounded
and for the normal distribution
we don't get that it's bounded we get
that it's almost boundary the
probability that it gets a large value
and
is very very small
and this is captured by
you can prove it for the normal
distribution by Computing the qnome of a
gaussian random variable and
so basically
yes
inequality
follows from this inequality
and when we take functions of degree one
and we have a function
we have
a similar probability for General low
degree functions so this is like one
function okay so this you might know
because this follows from turn off but
you can take the function that's the
number of triangles
foreign
and you can prove that it also has these
tail bounds that the probability that
it's large
it's very very small it's essentially
and
it's it's always it's valuable always
concentrated around it's too long
and so there are lots of yeah yeah
as an example you can take this function
which is function of the collection
and and
yeah so
I just I mentioned the
um
ah okay
and yeah so I just wanted to mention
that
these qnomes if if we have abound in the
qnome of a random variable then we have
this Markov inequality that we can apply
so the probability
of a random X in the cube
that f of x is at least
it's the same as the probability
f x to the Q is at least t to the Q
and this is at most uh the
this this is how upper bouncing queue
Norms translate into upper bounds in the
probability that the function takes
large values
and for us we care about Boolean
functions so we'll have
a function now that takes values in the
set 0 1.
and we would like to say things about
its full spectrum
and
the
main implication of a hyperconductivity
in that respect is that if we take a
Boolean function that takes the value
one with a very small probability
then all its Fourier math is
concentrated on the high degrees
and okay
so basically our goal is going to be
Autobahn
om
of this part
I want to say that this is smart
I don't remember
if I Define that
this F equal to D part is the sum of
exercise B of F and S Class
foreign
[Music]
that's a good question so
um it's relevant both to the KKL theorem
that we talked about so the the
um
and you know basically when you you want
to
Okay so
maybe I'll recall some stuff so
um so okay so so one motivation is from
the total influence that we talk about
so we have this ice influence of a
function
that's the probability over X in the
cube
awesome
we think of f as this voting scheme that
we have
to choose between -1 and 1 and then at
the end coordinates of the voters and
dice influence is the influence of the
dive bottles the probability that he
determined the outcome of the election
and there is the total influence which
is
some
of
um
and it turns out that this total
influence
as this population that
takes it has this nice formula
that it's the sum of effort times s so
basically when we know that all the four
mass of the function is on the high
degrees we also get the total influences
large because this s here is larger as s
increases so our goal is to Upper bound
the low levels in order to show that all
the masses on the high levels and then
we can upper bound the total influence a
lower balance
and we'll also talk about another
motivation of small set expansion
okay right so let's interpret this in a
different way
the claim is that if we take the two
norms
of the the greedy part of f
this is the maximum
is one
of and a g
is homogeneous of degrees
of the inner product between f and g
so basically this part it measures the
highest possible correlation
that F can have with the homogeneous
polynomial of the gradient
no
it does this is for Real valid function
for four functions so yeah
so maybe I let you tell me the proof so
why is this quantity at most distinct
difference
so if we take the inner product between
f and g
okay so by definition okay so f is the
sum over s and n o s
foreign
is only the sum over s of size d
of F at this guys object is
so this is
um
the same thing as the
um in a product between
some of all s of size d over F at s
Square yes
with g
that follows from possible that tells us
that in a product I mean these guys are
an autonomal basis so
and now we can apply a question to say
that this is at most
f equals
times the two Norm of G
which is one okay so this is why
we have this implication
why do we have the implication in the
other direction
yeah okay so you can take G to b f equal
to D divided by the two normal and we
get that this is inequality okay so this
is basically
so Auto bounce on this F equal to D
palettes are just uh upper bound to tell
us that if we have a Boolean function
it's not correlated with low degree
polynomials
okay so if we draw it
we have two types of distributions
we have
the distribution
of a Boolean function so it's the
indicator of some set for a the subset
of the Boolean Cube
and
let us write Alpha for the density of n
and then we can normalize f
1 so we'd have to divide by the square
root of alpha
and then
if we look at the distribution of f it's
going to have this peak here
it's going to take the value square root
of 1 over Alpha with probability Alpha
this is a very peaky distribution it
takes to speak
on the other hand we have this
a smooth distribution of low degree
polynomials
you know the grip polynomial you can
think of its distribution
as being a nice
and bounded
so it might take High values but only
with a very small probability
and then
this said difference in Behavior
is this is what makes Boolean function
that with a small Alpha so spouse
Boolean functions and correlated with
the low degree polynomials
Okay so
okay so we'll soon see how
hyperconductivity gives us this
uncovolution between Boolean functions
in low degree polynomials but
let's start with the trivial things
so if we have
um
so first what is the trivial upper bound
so we can always say that the two Norm
of f equal to D
this is at most
the two Norm of f
which is
square root of alpha
F only text the values zero and one so
this is like there
oh
and
let's say that we have a function G
we know the G is bounded so suppose the
G
the function detects value
in the interval minus MN
it only takes
um
yeah let's think of M as one or
something so G is a bounded function
then we can say that the inner product
between f and g
this is at most
the an Infinity Norm of G
times the L1 Norm of f so the
expectation of FG is at most M times the
one ohm of f so this is
going to be
Alpha times m
so when Alpha is small we get something
that's much smaller than the smooth
Alpha
and
and upper bounds on the Q Norm they let
us to get some inequality in between
this Alpha and this root Alpha so that's
going to be
and
for the application called the level the
inequality
I guess it's reasonable to attributes to
akl or to bks correction
um
and what
okay so he tells us that if we have a
function f
from
the Boolean Cube
zero one
and the expectation of f
Alpha
then the two Norm of f of the low degree
the degraded part of f
this is the most
and Alpha Square
so
exactly what to get from this example
but then you you'd have to pay some
logarithmic factors so
four
of one over Alpha
divided by D to the D
okay we need
B2B Atmos log 1 over Alpha
divided by
eight
roughly Alpha squared and then we have
this extra
poly logarithmic factors at least when
this constant and this statement is
effective
up to and log one over Alpha and that's
sort of why in KKL the CRM goes up to
log n
okay
so that is
foreign
so the idea is to
we take this two Norm Square
this is the inner product between
equal to D
does anyone have an idea what should we
do now
earlier with question that we put here
two and two
and then it gave us nothing
here we put infinity and one so
what can we do now in order to get
to use hyperconductively to get
something uh
yeah yeah so we can use handles
inequality exactly so we can
Autobahn below degree part it's Q moment
f
you can bound
and we can put the Q prime number
1 over Q Plus 1 over Q Prime is one this
is held in Elders inequality
and
okay then we have to choose Q
but let's first
okay so now we can have about up about
this part using hyperconductivity so
this is at most squared Q to the D times
the two Norm of f
and this part
this is the expectation of f
the power 1 minus one over Q
now both of them
okay
and we we sort of like to get rid of
this expectation of f to the one over Q
and
yeah
I just can't read it
today Tuesday
is it most something yeah
it's a problem
okay
yeah so
we would now like to get rid of this
expectation if
to the one over two and get this Alpha
Square dependence to get to the
expectation of f
so basically we choose Q
to be and log one over the expectation
of f
divided by D
and then we get the X expectation of s
one over Q
minus one over Q This is Just 2 to the D
if we take this log in base two and
we're already losing a score to the de
facto so we don't mind losing this extra
two to the factor so we get that this is
at most
what we had over there is at most two
squared Q
ready
times and
the norm of f equal to D times the
expectation of f
which is Alpha so now we can just
rearrange and we get
that
the norm of f equal to d square this is
most Alpha squared times four log one
over Alpha
will be
foreign
it turns out that this theorem for D
equal to one this is equivalent to
generous inequality and you basically
get some version of John of follow the
gray polynomial
are there any yeah
dyspo is definitely you know tight but
other than that yeah
yeah so I other than the the constant to
the this is
like a hummingbird
s
thank you
so
this is what the most of the mass of a
Boolean function is concentrated on the
high degree
and
okay another consequence that you can
get a bet is the small set expansion
theorem
and this is about a property of this
noisy process so
tell us the following
and
which I've seen on the existence
if we have a small set so such as if
we have a set of density at most Delta
and
then
we are going if we take a random step of
the random walk we are going to leave
the set with hyperbility
so if we choose randomly a random
element of a
and then we choose a random element
according to the size noisy random Mark
let's say and one half of X which
coordinate will remember remember it
with probability one half and forget it
with probability one half century sample
then when we do that
uh we can no longer guarantee that Y is
in a so we're going to leave a with a
high probability and so there isn't like
this set that you can it forces you to
stay inside every small set you're going
to leave
probabilities it's going to be the most
natural
and also and this you can also think of
geometry geometrically it means that if
you take
and
and if you look at the cube
and you have a small set a
then most of the elements in a are near
the boundary
it's like a high dimensional phenomenon
that if you take a ball
most of the elements if the random
element is going to be near the boundary
and it's going to get out of the set
with Hyper Mobility when you take
this random step
okay so let's move it
doesn't ask what's that
foreign
the expectation
over X in the cube
of
if you have f of x f of x
so f is the indicator
and then this is
the expectation of a y
F of Y
it's f of x
so this is just the expectation of X and
Y
and we get that this is the basically
the probability
expectation
over X
uniformly distributed over a
okay so we have this expectation over f
of x
you can get rid of that
so first we need X to be an A so this
happens with probability Alpha and after
we know that X is in a we have to take
this probability
this one this y
is in a
question a
and
what we want and what want to show that
and yeah so basically our goal
we want to show that this part is little
of one
this yeah so the goal is to Upper bound
okay
different okay sure
the goal is to show that the mobility
that Y is an a
that this is at most
um Epsilon so I want to show that
yeah so alternatively this is to show
that
the inner products
that most Epsilon times Alpha
which is Epsilon
thanks to the two Norm of f squared
don't plan for my mistakes
now how do we up about this thing we can
just use the full expansion so
this is the sum over s
of
to the S times f of x squared
and this is equal to the sum of the D
from 0 up to n of a half to the D
times the two Norm of the liquidity part
of f
and now we can and and then we can
divide it into two sums so we have the
sum over D which is at least
Epsilon
half to the D
ude it's going to be Epsilon because I
want to show the probabilities with more
exceptions
so this is at most then yeah so this is
this thing plus the same thing with the
smaller the logo to over Epsilon
and
so here we are going to Upper bound this
by a
so this is at most and this half today
becomes at Epsilon number two
and the the sum of all of these two
Norms this is at most two Norm of f
so the low degree part
and
we have
this inequality
so we can upper bound it by some
from b equal to zero up to
log 12 Epsilon
of
Alpha squared
one over Alpha
divided by D
minus 4 to the D
and we have maybe another extra half
today but the point here is that here we
have Alpha squared and it beats all the
other factors dishes
both Epsilon Alpha
provided the data is sufficiently small
what is stealth ticket use
CFO
Alpha is smaller than Delta so that's
why yeah
inequality
yes
inequality tells you that for HD app to
log 1 over Alpha
this level is negligible so all the mass
is up above level logo one over Alpha
yes
okay so either
so other qualities okay so one of them
is the isothermic uniformity which is
the simple so
okay
inequality yeah it tells us there's a
total influence of f
is at least
and
some constant times Alpha
log one over Alpha
it will alpha is that
let's say that this is at most
so we have a small set the total
influence of it is at least
log 1 over Alpha
so if you want to prove that the same
proof Works basically you have this
upper bound so let's just proof sketch
so
and
already smaller than log one over Alpha
divided by eight
and
this waitress Level D is negligible
you get that
the sum of the at least logo one of
alpha today
at least
two Norm of f over 2.
is m
Alpha 2.
so all of the mass of the most of the
mass of the function is above the level
of 1 over Alpha
as mentioned the total influence of f
is the sum of s times F at s squared
so we get that this is at least
log one over Alpha
over 16
times Alpha so we get
that
business Mass here at least Alpha over 2
and it's multiplied by this s which is
always going to be at least log 1 over
Alpha
okay so that's
for the iso parametric inequality
and you have the KKL theorem
which is slightly more tricky that's the
concurrilineal theorem
but if
um
basically
and say if the all the influences of f
are smaller than Delta then
the total influence of f
is at least two to the minus o one over
Delta and
this is sufficient to imply this other
version of the cake alpheum that tells
you that the maximum influence is at
least Logan over n
okay so basically it's just if the
influences so small the total influence
is large
and okay so here we are the small set we
assume that we have this small set and
we got
in the other parametric inequality this
factor of log one over Alpha
in the KKL theorem we don't have a small
set okay calc theorem is for an
arbitrary a function to take expectation
one-half within half of the element but
then the idea is to use the fact that
the derivatives of the functions they
are small sets so if we take
and the set of x
such that f of x is different than f
and the difference when you change the
coordinates
this set is a small set
and therefore this set contains all its
mass on the high degree
so yeah yeah
it's less than one
thanks
so yeah so we have these derivatives
and
this is this is called like gif
now maybe
sorry
so you can let the if be f of x minus f
of x so you change the x coordinate
and this is the Fourier expression the
sum of all s that contain I
of F at s
Sky of s minus I so this is the discrete
derivative but it's also the derivative
of f as a polynomial
and then this is a small set or at least
this thing is a small set so we get that
most of the mass of the derivative is on
the height degrees
and then once you know that all the mass
of all the derivatives is on the high
degree you can get that also the mass of
f is on the height degrees
and this is what makes its total
influence large
okay so I think I'll stop here
any questions
hyperconductivity being this sort of
powerful tool can you show that the
noise operators hyper contracted I'm
curious how much do we know about like
um other operators hyperconductivity
like for example like Kaylee graphs like
uh how do you know if I give you a set
of generators for a calligraph can you
tell me whether or not the top that
Matrix will be hyper-contractive or not
is it does that make sense yeah that's a
good question so
um
so
hopefully at some point in this semester
we'll talk about
hyperconductivity on other settings so
you can
and ask for hyperconductivity in the
Symmetry group or
or
the billionaires what the gas man
and
[Music]
basically what
what we did here is we had this operator
that was hypercontractive
and we deduced
some bound on its eigenfunctions
and
we had this uh
approach fluorescent well instead of
like constructing
we manage and we contracted some
operator the type of conductive but it
was sufficient to imply this
eigenfunctions have this nice properties
and basically if you talk about Kelly
graphs uh
so so if there are normal
characteristics which means
the
generating status conjugations
the eigenfunctions always look the same
it's the same eigenfunctions so once you
prove you find any normal calligraph
that's hyperconductive you essentially
got these nice properties for all the
calligraphs that you care about and
any more questions
exactly uh like
uh if you change it exactly at the end
of the coordinates that's also a hyper
contraction so the example but uh the
real thing if you look at the at the
random walk then the spectral Gap
corresponds to something on the point
career inequality
and then the hyper connectivity
corresponds to something called The Log
table of inequality which is known to be
stronger so it implies a spectral Gap
but it's strictly stronger and there's
something in the middle called modified
log Sublime inequality which is
equivalent to
something called reverse
hyperconductivity which is like hyper
connectivity but for Norm is less than
two
okay so maybe with another group
let's take it offline so let's think
normal again
foreign